on the mound for the phillies it's zach
wheeler this guy had a big bounce back
start in milwaukee on monday that's the
last game that the phillies won and they
needed him to be just about that good
again here this afternoon this evening
12 and 9 of the year 291 the era and the
1-2 pitch all the way swinging a mess he
got him now no chance this is what i'm
talking about with that sinker right
here to right-handers and it is
devastating let it ball run in on those
guys right there and that's just a
really tough pitch for righty on righty
to handle and jimmy you didn't have to
deal with that at all i think thankfully
but
that's pretty scary when he's coming at
97 with that kind of movement
and wieder will try again he turns kicks
and deals in the pits swung on and
missed he got him change up
and trevor story down on strikes couple
of k's for wheeler to start a one two
three first kyle's first time we've had
to say this in a long long time he's
looking to bounce back he had a rough
outing against the giants seven runs in
four and a third
that ball's hit hard oh what a play by
story can he get it out
you bet oh wow
that is as good as it gets
period end of subject
segura can't believe it
i mean this ball was hammered off the
bat
trevor barely has enough time stepping a
dive rolls over
and throws a one hop strike
to cj crone at first base
just in time one out and that'll bring
up ryan mcmahon
this ball pulled down the line fair ball
and that is a long run for harper
because he was way over in right center
field mack
is
gonna lay down for a second and hustle
back you see the skid mark there he was
headed to third and they kind of put a
power slide on and said i better not
yeah i think that was uh a good decision
for discretion right there given the
fact that we could see bryce harper pick
up that baseball a little bit before
ryan mcmahon passed second base on the
subaru super bowl you see he gets a
fastball up 3-1 count
just past veerling then it rattles
around down in that corner harper's got
the arm that you really don't want to
challenge and i think for mac he wasn't
sure so as soon as he hit second he made
his mind up
that goes off the glove of real muto and
the rockies catch a big time break
see how philadelphia plays this with one
out
early in the game do they bring the
infield in the 2-0 pitch coming to
dawson
chop to short runner breaks for the
plate for gregorius with the play at
home
joe girardi brought him in and it pays
off immediately on the chopper by dasa
to dede
and i love that call you have your ace
on the mound understanding the
importance that showing urgency that
your team and also to zach that look
we're not giving an inch that if they're
going to get it they're going to earn
every single run they get but we're not
going to let them hit a ground ball to
shore hit a ground ball to second and
let the run story you don't do that
segura off the glove of rogers wow
boy had rogers caught that one gene just
might as well might as well walked all
the way back to the clubhouse said i
quit yeah
dazza a couple of steps towards left
center against harper here's the pitch
and he takes that's off the plate away
ball four inside you on the other hand
you could throw the head and drive the
ball
did he go no
and the left-hander with the 2-2 pitch
breaking ball swinging a miss he got him
three balls no strikes on dede freeland
ready he kicks here's the pitch
up and in ball four
nearly hit him he walked him and a run
is home as the phillies take
a one to nothing lead so freeland trying
to escape with just the one run it's
oduba herrera they really need to cash
in
a bunch a sneak attack oh duble gets it
done and rolls underneath the glove of
mcmahon
two-run score how about a bunt double
well that'll get it done it's
three-nothing phillies
it's two runs that come home to score
and you can't give an error there i
don't think i mean he reached down
bare-handed he couldn't get it
he might have slowed it down a hair
gets behind him and
it's got to be a double
a bunt double how about that
here's gene segura hard hit single as
last time up and here he swings and
drives one deep to left tapia looks and
that is gone gene segura first ball
swinging
has homer to left center field it's his
12th of the year
and the phillies tack on another run
it's four nothing here in the fifth
is that fastball
up probably a little bit middle in and
those hands were rapid boy he just
jumped all over it
smoked it to left field and
well out of the ballpark trevor story a
strikeout and a ground ball to dede
gregorius
this ball crushed to left field
take a good look you won't see it for
long second deck shot
for trevor story
you get that right yes sir
21st of the year
i don't know if you saw this bat flip
curveball after two fastballs in
i love the bat flip from trevor the
super super mow we might get a good shot
it just explodes out of his hands
that's a long flight
brad miller in there to hit for matt
verling here to begin the seventh
high in the air in the right
blackman back track wall
see you later
a pinch hit home run brad miller
the phillies back up by four it's a 5-1
game in the seventh
this guy has a net before driving the
ball out of the yard and
time and time again
joe's put him out there to pinch him and
he's delivered that was one out here is
harper getting to face a right-handed
pitcher for the first time tonight
high and deep watch this baby sale
oh bryce harper
leaving vapor trails out of citizens
bank park it's 6-1 phillies there's
number 31.
that is a long night we've seen plenty
balls bounce off the mound
ryan howard hit some up in that area but
not many edges everybody go that
direction up to that second level the
the bushes over the floor
two out of the eighth
that time it's hit down the right field
line by mcmahon nice adjustment he made
to third as chrome they'll send him
so aguero with a relay to the plate tag
got him at home
wow what a relay harper segura riyal
muto how about guys this play by jt rio
muto
that throw was not a great one from
segura
took him to the first base side of home
plate but to catch it and get back to
slap in that tag and avoid an event
on the ground into the shift there's the
shortstop gregorius to end the ball game
and then the four-game skid for the
phillies
back into the win column and a much
needed one here tonight